paris ce n'était qu'une étape le convoi
dit de la liberté poursuit sa route
après une mobilisation mouvementée dans
la capitale les manifestants se sont
élancés de villepin direction lille
avant de rallier bruxelles à destination
finale de la mobilisation le convoi est
attendu demain dans la capitale belge
pour une convergence européenne notre
reporter david car il faille sur la
route vous voyez ces précisions
nous sommes sur la route en direction de
l'aéroport de lesquin à lille alors il
ya eu un premier rassemblement ce matin
sur le parking de l'associer à
villepinte un dans le nord de paris ils
s'étaient organisés afin de de faire un
petit déjeuner à c'est un convivial et
puis très rapidement ça c'est ça s'est
accéléré si vous voulez parce que un
premier convoi s'est fait stopper à
fontainebleau et par crainte de se faire
stopper par les forces de l'ordre et
bien le convoi décidé de partir de façon
morcelée et de façon non distinctes afin
de ne pas attirer l'attention sur le
convoi le premier stop sera l'aéroport
de lesquin de lille avant de rejoindre
la capitale belge dès ce soir alors
certaines informations à prendre avec
des pincettes avec pincettes évidemment
disent que éventuellement la frontière
pourraient être fermées alors je précise
bien que c'est des informations à
prendre avec pincettes c'est ce qui se
dit en tout cas dans le dans le convoi
de la liberté
la motivation est toujours là après le
journée assez éprouvante on peut le dire
hier après des manifestations violentes
des manifestations assez violente pour
à paris mais la motivation est toujours
là à force de détermination et de
persuasion pour ces gens qui eux ne
compte pas a lâché 1 pour la fin des
restrictions sanitaires pour récupérer
leurs droits fondamentaux et manifester
pour leur liberté voilà leur principal
objectif
et comme vous le disait dans ce convoi
de la liberté il est parti de façon
assez morcelé pour ne pas attirer l
attention je vous propose d'écouter
quelques uns des manifestants qu'on a pu
interroger un sur le parking ce matin
c'est quelqu'un même assez remarquable
c'est que dans le pays des droits de
l'homme
la répression est la plus sauvage 1
puisque depuis les gilets jaunes ne
savons très bien que ce gouvernement de
macron n'hésitent pas à tirer sur des
gens désarmés pacifique et s'ils nous
allons à bruxelles et que comme tout le
monde sait il est le président de
l'europe nous nous attendons à la même
chose mais là pour la liberté on est là
pour nos enfants pour nous pour nous
mais pour nous nos vieux pour aussi
pouvoir d'achat qui en train de
dégringoler depuis quelques mois et ceci
pour montrer notre mécontentement du
gouvernement que ce soient français ou
européens qui nous mène une politique
sanitaire désastreuse donc voilà on
n'est pas anti vaccins on est content
les mesures sanitaires et on va dire
l'amygdale à côté d'une certaine
population qui refuse de ce qu'il est au
gouvernement et à l'idéologie sanitaires
tels ras-le-bol de tous les citoyens je
vous dis que ça soit français labège
c'est tout le monde en a vraiment ras le
bol et on n'est pas écouté et regardé
comment on ne répond on ne répond par
une présence policière par des fourgons
de l'armée par des blindés alors que
nous on à l'envi avec nos voitures
personnelles on met de l'argent dans nos
voitures et on est reçu comme de la
merde voilà les convoyeurs de la liberté
ne pas baisser les bras à l'idée d'une
convergence européenne est toujours en
tête pour eux elle la route vers l'île
et bien et bien lancée pour pour toutes
ces voitures même si je vous le disais
on a on n'a pas l'image puisque ils sont
partis tous de façon morcelée afin de ne
pas attirer l'attention sur eux et pour
éviter un blocage l'idée aussi est
d'arriver à la frontière belge parc
plusieurs endroits différents pour ne
pas ne pas se faire stopper à la
frontière belge et atteindre bruxelles
pour cette convergence européenne du
convoi de la liberté